summer was around the corner and I
wanted to give you an edge on all your
peers that are gonna be probably reading
all these articles saying five books to
read during summer an article that pops
out June 21st I wanted to get my five
recommendations to you because I know
many of you guys have been asking about
it what book should I read this summer
so let me get right into it first book
high-output management by Andy Grove
Andy Grove was the former Man of the
Year Time magazine 1997 he passed away
three years ago he wrote another book
that I love called only the paranoid
survive just so everybody knows majority
of the management companies companies in
Silicon Valley that have management
philosophies they swear by Andy Grove
Andy Grove is every way he wrote like
everything about you know how to take
your lunch break how to do your meetings
how to orchestrate a meeting how to do
accountability everything he wrote in
this book in this one manual so again
what you'll notice about every day every
book I'm recommending to you for this
summer is every one of them has to do
with you become a better leader better
executive better CEO better I've given
you no feedback coaching to the people
that you work with and this is probably
at the top of the list of these five
books so high output management by an
integral next one it's called
trillion-dollar coach it's the story of
Bill Campbell Bill Campbell the reason
why they call the you know the trillion
dollar coach and it's written by Eric
Schmidt which I think was the former
executive chairman of Google for like 14
years some timeline like that and Bill
Campbell was a football coach before and
he started coaching and mentoring
multiple founders and seals that build
trillion-dollar companies such as Gates
you know Jobs Bezos like he is a legend
on what he did and his style of
leadership is a very very unique when
his funeral came I mean it must have
been a richest funeral ever with people
with the highest net were being there
and everybody has something to say about
him about how he impacted their lives
good luck trying to put this book down
you will not be able to put this book
down the trillion dollar coach highly
recommend you go get it
ASAP next one the CEO next door this is
about a study date that I think around
2600 different CEOs and identifying the
four drivers that helps somebody become
a great CEO for drivers I get people who
want to work with this
and they want a little bit deeper than
that I'm not gonna get into everything
but it's a very powerful book for you to
realize out of these twenty six hundred
leaders CEOs that they studied what
trends did they come up with what can
the clues that it leave on what did well
and what didn't do well so again another
great book to read this summer is the
seal next door by Elena
Botello and Kim Powell phenomenal book
this one I also couldn't put down to the
point where I had everybody in our
company read it it's called multipliers
by Liz Wiseman it's the story of how
some people and organizations they're
always multiplying themselves they're
developing other leaders and some are
diminishers and you'll notice an
organization doesn't at all build any
leaders or somebody you watch and you'll
say you know I'd never see that person
ever build leaders around them why is
that because there's certain tendencies
that diminishes people around you versus
multiplies people around you and she
gets really deep into it on exactly what
it is to be a multiplier so another
great book I recommend you for this
summer in Alaska at least somebody I had
as a guest before I've never recommended
this book highly recommend this book
sold nearly four million copies it's by
Jordan Peterson called twelve rules for
life if you haven't want to read this
book yet I would tell you one thing
about Jordan Peterson the way he thinks
is very different very different the way
he breaks things down very different if
you're a man wanting to find out what it
is on a way men are wired to be a man's
man he breaks it down in here if you're
a woman who is dating or is trying to
figure out how men are in business world
and personal life he explains it in a
way that's better than any book I've
read twelve rules of life and then it
applies to every aspect of your life as
well again there's a reason why he's got
a few billion views on Facebook and
YouTube combined everybody is curious to
know how this meant Jordan Peterson
thinks so
five book recommendations if you haven't
read these yet click on a link below I'm
gonna put a link for all the books for
you to go order them read the books let
me know what you take away from them if
you've read these books write your
reviews on the comments below what you
took away from these books and if you
haven't yet subscribe to the channel do
so by clicking the sub button and take
everybody bye-bye
you